[Music]
[Applause]
take it in take it in yeah now I know
you're all wondering why can I see this
big chicks bra simple question simple
answer this bra was $100 cuz if I pay
$100 for anything you're gonna see it
rest of my outfit 1788 now it's not an
issue with gay men grabbing my boobs
especially at brunch you're sitting
there drinking a mimosa all of a sudden
boom game man's hand right here pulsing
looking you in the face going oh girl
it's alright I'm gay that's why you
can't do it because no one puts the keys
in a Lamborghini starts to car and get
settled
so if you grab my boob you have a sex
with me gay man just not gay men
grabbing my boobs I got white women
putting their hands on my I froze see a
couple perpetrators in the world cuz
they're not classy when they put their
hand in your afro they don't want to
stay on the perimeter the Afro she don't
want to keep it Christian no she takes
the whole hand goes straight to the
scalp
shake it back and forth and then exit
your afro with this jellyfish action
while she's looking at her friend going
Laura and it's so soft it's like a
poodle it's so soft poodle really not
rubbing my fingers through your blonde
hair going oh it's like a golden
retriever
I was at the grocery store the other day
buying food cuz I'm a human you do it in
a guy at the register you know he's
checking me out but he's checking me out
cuz I'm pretty it's like hey girl yeah
you know I really like to take you out I
mean you know after you lose like twenty
thirty pounds
oh I'm sorry I couldn't hear you over
the minimum wage would you say don't
speak poverty I'm so sorry doing stand
up end up in a lot of weird places like
a couple weeks ago I was in a restaurant
eating something with gravy on it
catching hypertension as I do
it's a hot and the waitresses are
arguing with each other while serving
people food and the peace they resist on
to this argument is one of them looks
across the restaurants the other one it
says [ __ ] don't mess with me I'm from
Chicago who cares
as if geography denotes this girl's ass
whuppin ability like we all got the same
ass with an app on our phone and it's
like who's Chicago that's a 7.5 on the
ass of a river scale shape I'm Omaha you
better watch yourself Keisha
no this is the United States of America
okay the first world country if you're
from anywhere from America I'm not gonna
be afraid of you were you crazy but if
she dilutes across the restaurant and
said [ __ ] don't mess with me I'm from
the Congo
ma'am that [ __ ] a child soldier she
will kill you with a blow dart and a
sharpened banana
[Applause]